[Musique]
je suis et j'aime les boues je suis
romancière j'écris de nouvelles des
poèmes des chroniques dans la presse
voilà
[Musique]
je crois que dans tous mes romans je
reviens tard il ya toujours des
personnages importants qui sont des
pinceaux 9 de femmes
simplement parce que dans la vie je suis
la plupart des femmes ne sont sont
importantes et présente dans les
registres normal que ce soit que ça ce
que ça se répercute le lecteur est libre
de choisir ce qu'il veut dans un livre
envoyé au delà de ce que moi j'ai envie
de lui sera de lui transmettre le livre
rencontrera chez lui ou pas quelque
chose qui le concerne c'est sa liberté
l'écriture a un énorme pouvoir on écrit
pour que ça reste
et quand on écrit des choses violentes
où je veux dire on peut dire tout ce
qu'on veut absolument tout ce qu'on veut
mais écrire c'est pour être lu donc ça
nous lient d'une manière ou d'une autre
ça nous lient d'une manière ou d'une
autre il ya une rencontre
on ne peut pas anticiper ce que la
lecture d'un livre ou d'un poème va vous
apporter il a on est quel dans quelque
chose qui va se déclencher qui est qui
est parfaitement libre mais c'est ça qui
est beau dans l'art
[Musique]
je fais une différence très nette entre
la francophonie et la langue française
pour moi la francophonie c'est une
institution
c'est une institution à but politique
notamment parce que je viens d'afrique
subsaharienne francophone qui a un
rapport assez historique assez compliqué
à la francophonie
en revanche la langue française c'est
autre chose
la langue française pour moi c'est ma
langue en fait c'est la langue dans
laquelle j'ai été éduqué c'est la langue
dans laquelle j'écris je conceptual yves
lalanne dans laquelle je pars la maison
france je chante autres voilà c'est ma
langue
elle est ma langue en plus de mes autres
langues le fait que la langue française
m'appartiennent n'est plus discutable
voilà ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut me reprendre ce n'est pas ma langue
maternelle mais d'une certaine manière
mon lien il est peut-être encore plus
que le plus important qu'avec ma langue
maternelle qui est plus évidente
[Musique]